I have the distinct privilege of
introducing to you dr. Edward J Earl ER
doctor earlier is a professor of
political science at California State
University San Bernardino and is a
senior fellow of the Claremont Institute
he earned his BA from San Jose State
University and his MA and PhD in
government from Claremont Graduate
School he was a member of the California
Advisory Commission on the Civil Rights
from 1988 to 2006 served on the
California constitutional revision
Commission in 1996 and has testified
before the House Judiciary Committee on
the issue of birthright citizenship he
is the author of the American polity and
co-author of the founders on citizenship
and immigration which dr. Bob just
pointed out I had the privilege of
hearing dr. Erler speak on the
colorblindness of the Constitution last
year at the Supreme Court CCA and it was
extremely informative so again I had the
distinct honor and privilege to
introducing to you dr. Edward J earlier
thank you for that nice introduction
well today I think is a good day to talk
about the Second Amendment especially
after hearing the president last night
and I think everyone knows that we were
engaged in a rather frantic debate about
rights of gun owners and I think one
example should suffice to prove that we
are indeed engaged in a hysterical
debate about gun ownership one prominent
but I believe less than articulate
member of Congress alleges that
supporters of gun rights have become
enablers of mass murder to me that is
hysterical and I think everyone knows
that special animus has been directed at
so-called assault rifles and I think you
all know that these are not automatic
weapons because they require a trigger
pole for every round that is fired
automatic weapons have been illegal in
the United States since the 1930s some
of these semi-automatic firearms can be
fitted with large capacity magazines but
what probably inspires the ire of gun
control advocates is the menacing look
of these weapons somehow they don't
appear fit for polite society no a
law-abiding citizen could possibly need
such a weapon we are told they are
designed for one purpose to kill human
beings they surely are not designed for
hunting how many rounds from a
high-powered weapon do you need to kill
a deer you've heard that many times and
we are assured these weapons are not
well at
opted for self-defense only the military
and the police needs such weapons
senator Feinstein probably heard her as
well
confidently des claims that these
weapons of mass destruction have no
legitimate civilian use
don't forget we had an assault gun ban
for ten years and it had no appreciable
impact on crime rates whatsoever now
over the past two decades or so gun
ownership has increased dramatically at
the same time that crime rates have
decreased the obvious lesson is that gun
ownership is a deterrent to crime but
the progressives of all stripes deny
such a simple correlation most gun
crimes are committed with stolen or
illegally purchased or illegally
obtained weapons what is the right
formula to decrease crime I think it's
very simple increase the number of
responsible gun owners and prosecute to
the greatest extent possible under the
law those who commit gun related crimes
or illegally possess weapons it's a very
simple formula now one interesting fact
about gun violence is that assault
rifles are rarely used by criminals for
one thing they're not easily portable
nor are they easily concealed in Chicago
you probably know this is the murder
capital of the world excuse me of the
United States and perhaps the world I've
been to many dangerous places but I'm
very reluctant to go to Chicago
and you know they have draconian gun
laws in that city but murders are rarely
committed by assault rifles their
pistols are the weapons of choice
even for gang-related executions and
probably some of you have heard the
reports recently that it is safer to be
deployed to a war zone in Afghanistan
than it is to live in Chicago since we
know that so-called assault rifles are
not a significant factor in gun violence
apart from rare and spectacular events
does anyone doubt that the next target
of progressive gun control will be the
semi-automatic pistol the same arguments
apply why would any homeowner need such
a powerful weapon we are often told by
experts that a gun in the home is more
dangerous to the homeowner than to any
intruder and some people are
simple-minded enough to believe that not
anyone I might add who has taken an NRA
certified course in handgun use and by
the way senator Feinstein to the
contrary notwithstanding assault rifles
are superb home defense weapons
there is one assault rifle that is not
on the proposed list of banned weapons
the old
m1 carbine of World War two vintage and
Korean War vintage it's a 30 caliber
semi-automatic short barreled rifle that
hole that is capable of taking a
high-capacity magazine my apologies
President Obama is calling I hope there
are no drones nearby this m1 carbine I
believe is perfect for home defense to
say nothing of the ar-15 223 caliber
assault rifle which is similarly
suitable for home defense especially
with respect to a crime that has become
becoming more and more popular with
criminals and that's the home takeover
robberies in crimes where several
criminals
rushed the the home or attacked the home
simultaneously but of course we have
this horrible spectacle of the mass
shootings we are told that we have to
keep assault weapons with high-capacity
magazines out of the hands of people who
are prone to commit such atrocities and
the only way to do that is to ban these
weapons entirely but who are these
people the recent shootings Arizona
Colorado and Newtown were perpetrated by
mentally ill persons who by all accounts
should have been incarcerated even the
Los Angeles Times admits that there is a
connection between mental illness and
mass murder the LA Times
but the same people the same
progressives who advocate gun control
also oppose the involuntary
incarceration of mentally ill people who
in the case of the recent mass shootings
posed obvious dangers to society before
they committed their horrendous acts of
violence from the point of view of the
progressives who opposed involuntary
incarceration of the mentally ill and
here you can thank the ACLU and
like-minded organizations it is better
to disarm the entire population than to
incarcerate a few mentally ill persons
who are prone to engage in violent
crimes but we must not forget that each
of these shooters was also in possession
of semi-automatic pistols and I believe
that the Arizona shooting of congressman
Giffords only involved a semi-automatic
pistol the same argument for banning
assault rifles in order to keep them out
of the hands of mentally ill or mentally
unstable persons within by a parody of
reasoning apply to semi-automatic
pistols disarm the entire universe of
law-abiding citizens who owned
semi-automatic pistols said that none of
these weapons will fall into the hands
of the dangerously mental dangerously
unstable does it make sense to deprive
millions of law-abiding citizens of
their constitutional freedoms so that a
free there are a few suffering from
dangerous mental illness can remain free
such as the logic of those who inhabit
the world of progressivism but we must
be clear about one thing does the
president might say let us be clear the
Second Amendment is not about assault
weapons it is not about hunting and it's
not about sport shooting
it is about something much more
fundamental it reaches to the heart of
fundamental constitutional principles it
reaches to first principles one favorite
refrain of thoughtful political writers
during the founding era held that a
frequent recurrence to first principles
was an indispensable means of preserving
free government and so it is let me
first of all remind you of the text of
the Second Amendment I think you all
know it but it doesn't hurt to remind
ourselves of the language of the
Constitution a well-regulated militia
being necessary to the security of a
free State the right of the people to
keep and bear Arms shall not be
infringed I think we all know the
immediate impetus for this for the
amendment and it has never ended this
has never been in dispute
many of the revolutionary generation
believe that standing armies were
dangerous to Liberty militias made up of
citizen soldiers they reasoned were more
suitable to the character of republican
government expressing a widely held view
Eldridge
Jerry remarked in the debate over the
first militia bill in 1789 whenever
government means to invade the rights
and liberties of the people he said they
always attempt to destroy the militia
now the Second Amendment is unique in
that it that it contains its unique
among the amendments in the Bill of
Rights in that it contains a preface or
a prologue announcing the reason that a
right is protected let me paraphrase
since militias are necessary for the
security of a free State the right of
the people to keep and bear arms
may not be infringed now here we have to
read the words free state as a reference
not as a reference to the several states
that make up the Union the frequent use
of the phrase free state and the
founding era makes it I think abundantly
clear that the word state means here a
non tyrannical a non despotic or perhaps
even a non monarchical state now Justice
Scalia wrote the majority opinion in
District of Columbia versus Heller which
was handed down in 2008 rightly remarked
that the term free state and closed
variations seemed to have been terms of
art in the 18th century political
discourse meaning a free country or a
free polity and here the Justice Scalia
was correct now the the principle
constitutional debate leading up to the
decision in Heller centered around the
question of whether the right to keep
and bear arms was an individual right or
a collective right that is conditioned
upon service in the militia as a general
matter of course the idea of collective
rights was unknown to the framers of the
Constitution and it is this
consideration alone that should have
been decisive we have James Madison's
own testimony that the provisions of the
Bill of Rights as Madison said relate
first of all to private rights and
Madison did not indicate that the Second
Amendment was an exception along with
the other provisions of the Bill of
Rights it was meant to protect
individual private rights the notion
that there there are collective rights
is wholly I believe an invention of the
administrative state and the founders of
the administrative state the
progressives were engaged in a self
conscious effort to
supplant the principles of limited
government that we're inviting in the
Constitution the progressives argued
that what Madison and other founders
called the rights of human nature were
merely a delusion characteristic of the
18th century science they believed has
proven that there is no permanent human
nature there are only evolving social
conditions or what we might call today
social constructions for the
progressives what the founders called
nature or the rights of human nature are
either the epiphenomena
of the historical dialectic or simply
self well willed delusions indeed the
inherent the adherents of the
administrative state came to regard the
idea of individual rights as the enemy
of collective welfare after all and the
view of the progressives the welfare of
the community should always take
precedence over the rights of
individuals the welfare of the people
not liberty is the primary object of
government and government should always
be in the hands of experts this is the
real origin of today's gun control
hysteria professional police forces and
military have rendered the armed citizen
so we are told superfluous
we don't need armed citizens when we
have police and professional military no
individuals should be responsible for
his own defense or the defense of his
family leave it to the experts the
advent of the administrative state has
rendered the idea of individual rights
as well as the idea of individual
responsibility unnecessary in fact
incompatible with the progressive vision
of the common welfare now this way of
thinking
was wholly alien to the founders for the
founding generation government existed
for the purpose of securing individual
rights life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and it was always understood
that a necessary component of every
right was a correspondent individual
responsibility
Madison frequently stated that all just
and free government derives from social
compact all just and all free government
derives from social compact that's James
Madison and this is the very idea that
is embodied in the Declaration of
Independence which notes that the just
powers of government are derived from
the consent of the governed social
compact to use Madison words
contemplates a certain number of
individuals as meeting and agreeing to
form one political society in order that
the rights the safety and the interests
of each may be under the safeguard of
the whole the compact madison duly notes
must result from the free consent of
every individual the rights to be
protected by the political society are
those natural rights that are the
consequences of the first principles of
human nature that all men are created
equal these rights exist by nature they
are not created by government although
governments are necessary to secure them
thus political society rightly
understood understood as Madison
understood it exist to secure the equal
protection of the equal rights of all
who consent to be governed this is the
original understanding of what we know
today as equal protection of the laws
the equal protection of equal rights
no each person who consents to become a
member of civil society thus enjoys the
equal protection of his own rights while
at the same time incurring the
obligation to protect the rights of his
fellow citizens in this first instance
then the people are a militia the first
appearance of the people and the idea of
social compact is the people are a
militia formed for the mutual protection
of equal rights this makes it impossible
to mistake both the meaning and the
vital importance of the Second Amendment
the whole people are the militia and
disarming the people dissolves their
moral and political existence now we
remember that the preamble to the
Constitution stipulates that we the
people do ordain and establish this
constitution and it's important to
understand here is that the Constitution
doesn't create the people the people
create the Constitution well when did we
become a people
I think that's simple when we adopted
those first principles by which we were
to govern ourselves the Declaration of
Independence the Declaration of
Independence mentions to the people in
their political capacity we are one
people and it mentions the people in
their moral capacity we are a good
people once we become a people then we
establish the Constitution and Madison
says there was a second contract between
the people and the government the
government is established to protect the
safety and happiness of the people and
the people delegate powers to the
government to be used for the benefit of
the people for their safety and happen
powers are delegated to the government
and the government can exercise only
those powers and whatever powers are
fairly implied from those specifically
delegated powers the government is to be
a limited government confined to the
exercise of those delegated powers we
also remember that the Declaration of
Independence specifies that when
government becomes destructive of the
ends for which it is established again
the safety and Happiness of the people
then quoting the Declaration it is the
right of the people to alter or to
abolish it and to institute new
government this is what has become known
as the right of revolution and this is
an essential ingredient of social
compact and a right which is always
reserved to the people the people can
never cede or delegate this ultimate
expression of sovereign power thus a
very in a very important sense the right
of revolution or even its threat is the
right that guarantees every other right
and if the people necessarily have the
right of revolution as an indie feasible
aspect of their sovereignty then by
necessity the people have the right to
the means to revolution only in armed
people is a sovereign people and only in
armed people is a free people the people
are indeed a militia but we must
remember that the Declaration includes
an important Prudential lesson with
respect to the to the right to alter or
abolish government
prudence the Declaration says will
dictate the governments long established
should not be changed for light and
transient causes it is only after a long
train of abuses and usurpations pursuing
invariably the same object and that
object evinces a design to reduce the
people to absolute despotism it is their
right it is their duty to throw off such
government and to provide new guards for
their future security
now here the declaration identifies the
right of revolution not only as a right
of the people but as a duty and I might
add it is the only duty that is
mentioned in the Declaration of
Independence but again the Prudential
lessons of the Declaration are no less
important than its assertion of natural
rights the prospects of the dissolution
of government or the prospect is almost
too horrible to contemplate and must be
approached with the utmost
circumspection as long as the carts are
operating free and fair elections are
proceeding and the ordinary processes of
government hold out the prospect that
whatever momentary inconveniences or
dislocations the people experience can
be corrected then they should be
tolerated these do not represent a long
train of abuses and usurpations but we
cannot remind ourselves too often of
that oft repeated refrain of the
founders rights and liberties are best
secured when there is a frequent
recurrence to first principles now in
the District of Columbia versus Heller
case which was again in 2008 the Supreme
Court handed down a decision that for
the first time
held unambiguously that the Second
Amendment guaranteed an individual right
to keep and bear arms for the purposes
of self-defense and in support of this
opinion for the court Justice Scalia
quoted Blackstone's commentaries on the
common law of England or a work that was
well known of course the founders
Blackstone referred to the natural right
of resistance and self-preservation
which necessarily entailed he said the
right of having and using arms for
self-preservation and defense natural
rights of course are possessed by
individuals and one can easily see in
Blackstone's language the rights of
having and using arms a precursor to the
Second Amendment which says the right of
the people to keep and bear arms and
throughout his majority opinion Justice
Scalia rightly insisted that the Second
Amendment recognized pre-existing rights
rights that were not created by the
Constitution nor in any way dependent
upon the Constitution for their
existence but Justice Scalia I believe
was wrong to imply that the Second
Amendment rights were codified from the
common law as part of what he called our
venerable liberties they were in fact
natural rights deriving their status
from what the Declaration of
Independence called the law of nature
laws of nature and nature's God
now in his Heller dissent justice
Stevens boldly asserted that there is no
indication that the framers of the
amendment intended to enshrine the
common law right of self-defense in the
Constitution and now I think in a
perverse way justice Stevens was correct
the framers did not enshrine the common
law of self-defense
they recognize the natural right of
self-defense a right that is possessed
by every individual as well as the
people like the natural right to
revolution the right to self-defense the
right to self-preservation can never be
ceded to government or given up in any
way James Wilson who was a signer of the
Declaration of Independence as well as a
member of the Constitutional Convention
and later a member of the Supreme Court
made this statement the great natural
law of self-preservation cannot be
repealed or superseded or suspended by
any human institution but justice
Stevens nevertheless concluded that
because there is no clause in the
Constitution explicitly recognizing the
common law right of self-defense it
simply is not a constitutional right and
therefore cannot authorize the
individual possession of weapons of
self-defense it's remarkable what
justice Stevens apparently doesn't
realize is that the Constitution as a
whole is a recognition of the great
natural law of self-preservation both
for the people and for individuals
whenever government is unwilling or
unable to fulfill the ends for which of
the exist the safety and happiness of
the people the the right of action
devolves upon the people whether it is
the right of revolution or an individual
right defense to defend person and
property now Justice Scalia in his
majority opinion in Heller noted that
those who argued for the collective
rights interpretation of the Second
Amendment including justice Stevens in
dissent have the impossible task of
showing that the rights protected by the
Second Amendment our collective rights
whereas every other right protected by
the Bill of Rights is an individual
right why would the Second Amendment be
an exception
now it is true that the Second Amendment
states that the people have the right to
keep and bear arms other amendments
refer to the rights of the people
for example the Fourth Amendment the
right of the people in the fourth
amendment to be secure in their persons
homes papers and effects against
unreasonable searches and seizures but
there seems to be universal agreement
that the Fourth Amendment rights belong
to individuals not to the people as an
organic whole it is the individual who
has a right to be free from unreasonable
government intrusion
similarly the ninth amendment refers to
the rights retained by the people I
believe this is also an obvious
reference to individual rights but what
about the First Amendment's protection
of the rights of the people peaceably to
assemble and to petition the government
for a redress of grievances justice
Stevens argued that these rights were in
fact collective rights peaceable
assembly and the right to petition
collective rights after all he said they
contemplate collective actions it is
true the justices conceded that the
right to assemble is an individual right
but its concern is with action engaged
in by members of a group rather than by
any single individual at the right to
petition government for redress of
grievances is similarly he says a right
that can be exercised by individuals
even though it is primarily collective
in nature its collective nature the
Justice hoped helpfully explains means
that if they are to be effective
petitions must involve groups of
individuals acting in concert
even though individuals may petition
government for a redress it is more
effective and done in concert with
others even though the Justice admitted
concert
is not a necessary is not necessary to
the existence or the exercise of the
right now with respect to assembly the
Justice argues there cannot be an
assembly of one an assembly is a
collection of individual rights holders
who can have who have United for common
action or to promote a common cause but
who could argue that the manner in which
the assemblage takes place or that the
form that it takes significantly
qualifies or limits the possession or
exercise of the right we might as well
argue that freedom of speech is a
collective right because freedom of
speech is most effectively exercised
when there is an audit an audience or
when there are auditors of some kind or
another or that freedom of press is a
collective right because it's most
effectively exercised when there are
readers I can only conclude that justice
Stevens's argument is fanciful not to
say frivolous the argument for
collective rights fails now justice
Stevens also says that they preamble to
the Second Amendment identifies the
preservation of the militia as the
amendments purpose preservation of the
militia he would thus impose on the
imposter this impossible rendering upon
the plain text of the amendment here's
the way he would read the Second
Amendment well-regulated militias being
necessary to the security of the freedom
of the several states the right of the
members of the militia into several
states to keep and bear Arms shall not
be infringed but I don't think the
Amendment says that or anything close to
that
in order to reach this conclusion
justice Stevens has to make in
I think a wholly incredible argument
that the right to keep and bear arms
refers not indeed to to rights but only
to one listen to this the people have
the right to keep arms only when they
are actually bearing arms try to follow
me here not my argument and the people
can only bear arms while in militia
service if these were to rights the
right to keep arms in the right to bear
arms
then these the right to keep arms might
be interpreted to be at private right
even as the right to bear arms would be
a collective right reduce the to rights
to a single right and you have one
collective right that can be exercised
only while serving in a militia
I think this argument is either
frivolous or worse now justice Stevens's
contention also ignores the argument
that was prevailed at the founding that
the first appearance of the people the
whole people is in its capacity as a
militia dedicated to the equal
protection of equal rights justice
Stevens's view would allow government
regulation in effect to create special
militias a subset of the people who have
the right to keep arms only when they
bear arms the second amendment however
sought to prevent the danger to Liberty
that would be posed by such special
militias by properly defining the whole
people as the militia now Madison knew
as well as Blackstone how the Stuart
Kings had used special militias to
suppress Liberty particularly religious
liberty and a large part of Madison's
purpose was to prevent the formation of
special militias by emphatically
defining the whole people
as the militia because a militia is
necessary to the security of a free
State the people shall not be disarmed
the court however in the Heller decision
did indicate that there could be some
reasonable restrictions on gun ownership
Justice Scalia wrote that long-standing
prohibitions on the possession of
firearms by felons and the mentally ill
will continue to meet constitutional
muster
laws that forbid carrying firearms in
sensitive places such as schools and
government buildings are also reasonable
regulations as our conditions and
qualifications on the commercial sale of
arms the prohibition on dangerous and
unusual weapons including automatic
firearms fall outside the Second
Amendment guarantee as well but the
Heller decision is clear that handgun
possession for self-defense is
absolutely protected by the Second
Amendment can handguns be carried
outside the home is part of the inherent
right of self-defense clearly the court
indicated that handguns can be
prohibited in sensitive places but what
about places that don't have the same
sensitivity as schools and government
buildings surely not every place outside
the home is a sensitive area and if
carrying weapons in a non sensitive
areas protected by the Second Amendment
can there be restrictions on concealed
carrying these are all questions that
will have to be worked out in the future
if not by legislation than by extensive
litigation and the Supreme Court took a
further important step in securing
Second Amendment rights in McDonald vs
Chicago case that was handed down in
2010 here the court ruled that the
second Second Amendment rights as
articulated in the Heller case were
fundamental rights and thus binding on
the states through the Due Process
Clause of the Fourteenth Amendment but
here I think Justice Thomas in his
concurring opinion had a better argument
when he said that the framers of the
14th amendment included intended to
include all substantive rights including
Second Amendment rights to be cain't
contained in the privileges or
immunities Clause of the Fourteenth
Amendment and I think his opinion had a
more accurate reading of the historical
record then the four members have made
up the mid for other members have made
up the majority of the court but
apparently the court has invested too
much effort in its substantive
substantive due process jurisprudence as
changes month to change its mind at this
late date now but we must always keep in
our mind that these two important
decisions in Heller and McDonald were
five to four decisions very close
decisions new appointments of more
should we say more progressive minded
judges to the court could easily bring
about a reversal for the moment the
Second Amendment rights seemed safe but
in the long term a political defense
will be a more effective strategy for
those who want to defend Second
Amendment rights I think in the current
climate of public opinion Congress will
probably have a very little appetite to
pass for passing an assault gun ban more
likely Congress will be satisfied with
passing legislation
aimed at gun trafficking or perhaps
tightening laws about background checks
but we must remember that President
Obama is famous for saying if Congress
won't act then I will
he has already issued at my last count
at least 23 executive orders
some of them tightening background
checks others asking various executive
agencies to launch gun safety programs
directing all relevant executive
departments to maximize efforts to
prevent gun violence and prosecute gun
related crimes and so on this all seems
to be fairly straightforward other
executive orders are rather curious one
notes that there is nothing in the
Affordable Care Act that prevents
doctors from asking patients about guns
in the home and other directs the
Centers for Disease Control to
researching the cause and prevention of
gun violence now there is no doubt that
the president's power to act through
executive orders is as extensive as it
is ill-defined Congress routinely
delegates power to the executive branch
and its agencies and courts accord great
deference to agency rulemaking powers
often interpreting an ambiguous
legislative language or even legislative
silence as a delegation of power to the
executive branch
now delegation of course provokes
fundamental questions of separation of
powers and even the rule of law but many
have argued that extensive delegation of
legislative power to the executive
branch is the price that we have to pay
for the modern administrative state
separation of powers and the rule of law
is understood by the framers we are
has been rendered superfluous by the
development of the modern state some of
the boldest supporters confidently tell
us that the triumph of the
administrative state has propelled us
into a post constitutional era where the
Constitution no longer matters I'm sure
some of you have already gotten that
feeling yourselves the president already
has the power under the Gun Control Act
of 1968 some of you may remember that
piece of legislation he already has the
power to ban the importation of assault
rifles the Act gives the president the
discretion to ban guns he doomed deems
not suitable for sporting purposes would
the president be bold enough perhaps
even reckless enough to issue an
executive order banning the domestic
manufacture and sale of assault rifles
perhaps he could argue that these
weapons have no possible civilian use
and should be restricted to the military
and that he his power as
commander-in-chief authorizes of him to
act or perhaps sometime in the near
future the president will receive a
report from the Centers for Disease
Control that gun violence has become a
national health epidemic with a
recommendation that the president
declare a national health emergency the
president by executive order may then
order the confiscation of all assault
weapons Congress surely could pass
legislation to defeat the executive
order but could a divided Congress
muster the votes and in any case the
president would veto the legislation
surely we would have resort to the
courts but as of yet we have no ruling
that assault weapons are not one of the
exceptions that can be banned or
regulated under the hell
decision we could make the case that
assault rifles are useful for
self-defense in the hotend home defense
but could we make the case that they are
essential would the courts hold that the
government had to demonstrate a
compelling interests for the ban on
assault rifles as it almost certainly
would have to do if handguns were at
issue all of these questions presuppose
that the Heller decision is still
standing which it may not be are these
simply wild speculations on my part
perhaps probably but they are part of
the duty we have as citizens to engage
in a frequent recurrence to first
principles and I thank you for listening
so I can take some questions if
anybody's interested I think you have to
take a microphone so I recorded all of
this for posterity or until tomorrow
morning whichever comes first
Stewart Reuter your discussion of the
writer revolt
revolution revolution raises the
question of the legality of the
Confederate States of America see
session now one that one interesting
point I received a question like this
all the time
one of the interesting things that the
South never did or the Confederate
states never they never justified the
secession on the basis of the right of
revolution why because that is a natural
right argument in which case they would
have had to somehow distinguish or argue
around the fact that on the basis of
natural rights their slaves had a
natural right to freedom and so they
knew better than to make a natural right
argument for revolution as being the
basis of their secession so they never
argued that yes okay well sorry can we
go back to the preamble for the Second
Amendment and and make make sure I
understand your position it sound quiet
for said is that Yambol doesn't inform
or constrain or otherwise affect the the
subsequent language of the Second
Amendment is that the case the amendment
be the same have the same meaning
without difficult to say but I think
that that it is unique in the sense that
is the only amendment that has a
preamble or a preparatory statement
there the people have the the people how
would it read without the preamble to it
the the people have the right to keep
and bear arms well I think that it would
have the same meaning perhaps we've been
confused by the preparatory remark
because
that we're not prone to extra rewards
but I think Madison wanted to make it
clear I mean they were really important
about this idea that militias were
important and that I really do want to
emphasize the idea that if Madison said
and he repeated this is an article a
long time ago when I was a young
professor you know you have to have a
lot of footnotes in your in your
writings and so I counted up every time
that Madison said or made the statement
that all free government and all just
government proceeds from social compact
there was many many times so it's just
something that he said frequently and we
have to take it seriously so that means
that we we all a consent to be governed
and we all agree to protect one
another's rights at the same time that
our rights are being protected and this
means that the people in this first
compact that is made are in effect a
militia that's how we become a people is
by becoming a militia pledged one to
another to protect one another's rights
and so this is what Madison had in mind
now Congress has the power under the
Constitution to determine the kind of
training for militias and so on and so
forth so a well-regulated militia and
the first militia acts defined the
militia as everyone between the ages of
I forget 18 and 45 or everyone who has
the capacity to serve in the militia and
so on and so forth so in essence the
people are a militia and they have and
no one who is unwilling to serve in the
militia or to protect the rights of
other persons has any right to be become
a part of the body politic we can if we
want to we are not obliged to but we can
if we want to grant conscientious
exemptions for people because of
religion and so on and so forth but
there is no requirement that we do so
based upon this idea of social compact
that Madison said was it the foundation
of all just and free government yeah
yes um um senator Feinstein's
um dan things that's a little different
as I understand from the 1994 ban is
that owners while their grandfather did
they have own assault weapons they're
not allowed to either resell those
weapons or hand them down to their heirs
that's great if that means to me that
they are not allowed to recover their
investment in that property in that
weapon and isn't that a violation of the
Fifth Amendment's no person shall be
deprived of life liberty or property
without due process or the takings
clause yeah you could look at it that
way but of course no one if you have
owned something that is illegal then of
course you have no right to you know no
one has a right to inherit that property
in any case so the idea would be whether
the government can by legislation ban
assault weapons or not if it's legal to
abandon you know to ban assault weapons
then of course the idea of them being
inherited and so on and so forth would
follow in the wake of that decision as
well but that's just that's just
legislation if if I have a grandfather
in California no we have some pretty
strict laws in California I have
actually I I should have mentioned the
m1 carbine but I it'll probably be on
the list tomorrow and you know I hope I
didn't make a mistake there but I have
grandfathered weapons but that's by
legislation in California and there is a
proposal in California to to stop
grandfathering weapons that are already
owned and that's would be perfectly
legal under the California Constitution
you could look at it that way if they if
the California legislators I want to
take the political heat for it and then
they could do that I knew we would of
course get a legal case right away and
try to force the you know the courts to
decide otherwise but who knows what the
decisions would be so how do you see the
role of the local sheriff in the defense
of the Second Amendment well it's been
interesting there's been a lot of
rumbling around the country some
sheriff's say they won't enforce the
assault gun ban some sheriffs are saying
to people that you should arm yourselves
don't depend upon the police anymore and
I I think that these are probably not
good things for sheriffs to be saying
but I admire that kind of spirit in the
country and I'm glad to see that that
kind of spirit in the country is still
alive and people are willing to say
those kinds of things but if it's a
federal law and you know we have the
Supremacy Clause in the Constitution
then we have to obey the law can we
count it as one of those pieces of
usurpations that pursuing invariably the
same end to reduce the people to
absolute despotism maybe but you know
this is gonna be a difficult thing some
sheriff's and police departments are
welcoming this ban and some sheriffs and
police are saying the people should arm
themselves I think sheriffs and you know
police chiefs are political people and
they're most likely to be on the side of
disarming the people but I can tell you
that your ordinary policeman knows that
an armed homeowner helps the police and
I think into any policeman will tell you
not any policeman but most policemen
will tell you something like that and it
really is true that an armed citizenry
that's what reduces crime I mean look at
Chicago
I mean how can you argue against that
and it's not assault weapons that are
causing all the violence in Chicago I
guarantee you that can you say a few
words about where in the Constitution
there's a basis for the ban on exotic or
powerful weapons does the Constitution
say we can't have nuclear weapons well
when the court in the DC case says you
know unusual or dangerous weapons
I think that this is a reasonable thing
look we the Constitution says Congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or you know
interfering in the free exercise of
religion but if you have a religion that
requires you to to make human sacrifices
I think it's reasonable to say that you
can believe in human sacrifice you just
can't do it or that freedom of speech
doesn't allow you to libel or slander
because civil society you know libel is
a way of taking a person's property
because your reputation is your property
so libel is taking a person's property
without due process of law so we have
these reasonable restrictions and
regulations
automatic weapons we could have an
argument about that whether or not they
are dangerous or unusual weapons
probably you know I have many many years
ago a military experience and and my
weapon when I was in the Army was an m60
machine gun I loved that weapon and I
wish I had one now
but I don't think that every armed
citizen should have an m60 machine gun
there you know I have to have a lot of
training to fire them and to handle them
properly and so on and so forth
should everyone have a grenade launcher
I don't think so probably not flame
thrower probably not you
an Abrams tank probably not although I
wish I had one of those too but make
driving on the freeway in California a
lot easier but but so we can have an
argument about reasonable restrictions
for gun ownership I do not think that
assault rifles and I hate to use that
term but it's in common parlance now but
assault rifles I do not think are the
weapons that that should be should be
banned or restricted I mean when people
say they're no good for any kind of
civilian use that's simply not true
get yourself an m1 carbine and ten and
get back to me and tell me that that
thing is not useful it is
well but but that's the way at all yeah
it that but that's the way no you're
you're right that but that's the way it
always is we have to make judgments
about these things what kind of speech
should be allowed you know clear and
present danger this is a standard for
speech we're going to allow people to
you know falsely yell fire in a crowded
theater that's the example that's always
used of course we can restrict that
speech but the First Amendment says
Congress shall make no law but we can't
have people saying you know anything
they want to at any time in any place
and so on so time place and manner
restrictions upon speech those are
reasonable regulations and so everything
can be subjected to that and of course
we have to make judgments we have to
make decisions about things that's why
we have legislators who were supposed to
deliberate about things they don't often
deliberate very well we have courts that
are supposed to deliberate look how long
it - I didn't think that I would live
long enough to see a Supreme Court
decision saying that second Amendment
rights were individual rights you know I
actually prayed for for that for years
and years and years and then we finally
got it in 2008 I never thought we would
see it I don't know how many years it's
going to that decision is going to stand
but you know we finally got it so that
was significant progress but so now we
have to make a decision somebody's going
to come along and I think if senator
Feinstein gets her way on assault rifles
somebody's going to come along and say
well wait a minute the Supreme Court
case said and Heller said that handguns
are the weapons of choice for the
homeowner does that mean a
semi-automatic handgun you know who
needs a 45 semi-automatic pistol I mean
that's a powerful weapon the homeowner
doesn't need that I mean why can't we go
back to black-powder pistols or
something like that and so you know
we've got to make decisions and and
that's what we have to do always and so
free exercise of religion we can't let
people do whatever they want to
and the Supreme Court said in the case
in I think was around 1880 if we allowed
a free exercise exemption based upon
everybody's view of what was proper to
his religion everyone could become a law
unto himself because you could say my
religion doesn't allow me to obey that
law so everyone could become a law unto
himself so we have to have all kinds of
regulations and reasonable restrictions
upon what can be allowed under the guise
of free exercise of religion no
cannibalism no human sacrifice and so on
and so forth
so and I suspect the same thing is is of
truth gun ownership as well and so we'll
have all kinds of arguments I think we
ought to draw the line on assault
assault rifles we have to stop calling
them assault rifles for one thing but we
ought to draw the line there I don't
think that they should be banned
although I I'm not too concerned about
people owning automatic weapons or
mortars I'd like to have a mortar - okay
thanks